okay so spider-man now at home wraps up
a lot of things in tom holland's first
trilogy but that doesn't mean that there
aren't questions still up in the air
over the film throughout this video
we're gonna be giving answers to the
biggest head scratchers floating around
about the movie to hopefully give you a
better understanding of it full spoilers
ahead and if you haven't seen it then be
warned i can't perform a memory spell to
make you forget what happens however if
you enjoyed the breakdown then please
hit the thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe for videos like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's cure some ass
okay so the biggest question that
everyone has after leaving the cinema is
will peter pay his rent on time it's an
issue that he's had before and we end
with him getting a brand new apartment
but without a job it's gonna be
difficult now peter is also studying for
his ged and thus i think he'll actually
start working for the daily bugle we
already know from the tick tock page
that betty brant now has a job there and
if peter starts supplying them with
pictures of spider-man it could lead to
him being able to make enough money to
live on if you think about it the bugle
slams spider-man from the start of this
movie and it would totally make sense
that the mcu version would be the kind
of person who tried to repair his
reputation i can totally see this peter
trying to go over to them to try and get
them to change their minds by supplying
them with pics of the web head doing
good deeds however jameson will of
course twist these and it would add a
really interesting dynamic having him
trying to ruin spider-man's reputation
whilst peter is trying to repair it now
in the wake of the ending one of the big
questions i've seen that might not be as
important as the rent one is is peter
still part of the avengers well no he's
not the spell that strange cast at the
end completely destroyed all of the
relationships that he had and it made
everyone forget peter parker existed the
kid had pretty much done the forgot
about dre song but in real life and now
no one knows who he is beyond this it
includes all of the avengers and as they
know peter on a personal level he
wouldn't be part of the group in far
from home we also learned that nick fury
and shield were well aware of who he was
and therefore everyone in the government
is also under this spell too i'm
guessing this includes the scrolls and
spider-man's identity will be completely
hidden from absolutely everyone i'm not
sure what happens with the cabinet at
school that has peter and spider-man's
face side by side but the way that this
spell works is that it basically
hypnotizes people just in the same way
that during an act on stage a magician
can ask someone their name and they're
unable to say it the spell stops you
tapping into the part of your brain that
retains this information now how this
would work with the stand and video
recordings of say the beagle's reports
i'm not too sure but i can imagine that
it would go one of two ways either
someone walking past the stand or seeing
a video would simply go into a trance
and skip past it or it would work like
the silence in doctor who in case you
haven't seen them they're basically
aliens that you completely forget about
the second that you look away from them
you can be staring one in the face
absolutely terrified and then when you
turn around it'll be like you never saw
them now we probably won't learn exactly
how this works until the next movie but
the way that it worked in the comics was
that it pretty much just stopped people
from remembering the details thus peter
is truly just once more your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and much in the
same way that daredevil operates he's
just classed as a vigilante that lives
in new york this is hammered home by the
report that jameson gives at the end in
which he says that spider-man destroyed
the statue of liberty and that the
vigilante is concealing his identity
although it's a downer i do think it
very much gives the character a fresh
start and it means that they can
introduce new people and relationships
such as harry osborn black cat gwen
stacy and really anyone who we can
slowly reveal the truth to over time he
could also spark up somewhat of a
friendship with happy asset to both
visit mae's grave at the end and
potentially they could come to know each
other once more either way peter is now
fully on his own in a new apartment no
longer going off with mj and ned to
boston and whilst one door closes
another one opens for the future now i
actually have a suspicion that sony and
marvel put this in place just in case
they couldn't come to an agreement over
whether they'd be working on films
together in the future being completely
disconnected from the other marvel
heroes would mean that he would still be
classed as being in the mcu but they
wouldn't have to worry about the
contractual things and stories clashing
we do know that tom holland has signed
on for more movies as the webhead though
and i am excited for the direction of
the franchise now we don't know if the
spell actually extends beyond the mcu
and potentially it could also go into
other universes if sony ever picked up
the amazing spider-man 3 or potentially
spider-man 4 we could explore the
repercussions of that i think it would
add a lot of drama to toby's life if he
returned home to find that his mj had
forgotten who he was too and he could
even team up with andrew in the future
in the same way that spider gwen is
having another adventure with miles now
just before peter is thrown into the
mirror dimension strange pushes him out
of his astral form he goes to grab the
box but peter moves it out the way and
this is because his spider sense is
naturally protecting his body from harm
his spider senses very much his
instincts just reacting and that's why
he constantly keeps moving the box out
of the way peter's spider sense is very
much a part of its nervous system and
muscle memory and therefore it
constantly keeps moving even when he's
not fully in control of his body now
another question i've seen being asked a
lot centers around the villains and what
happened to them while solizard and
sandman weren't killed in the movies
that they appeared in we do learn that
they're doomed to die and it's clear
that they turn back to a life of crime
in their own realities though we don't
see their deaths we know it was their
fate to die and some of the lines that
are dropped in the movie hint towards
the other spiderman becoming lethal
protectors andrew garfield says that
after gwen's death he got bitter and
stopped pulling his punches had he come
across the lizard once more i think that
he wouldn't have held back don't forget
that this is the guy who killed gwen's
father and thus he very much stands as a
symbol of pain for this version in the
amazing spider-man we watched as the
transformation wasn't permanent whereas
in this film it is so i think that the
version we meet would have been one from
years later that had perfected the
formula in the post-credits scene of the
movie he was visited by the gentleman
who was clearly putting together a team
so we might learn down the line exactly
what happened with him as for the
sandman he also killed uncle ben and had
he turned back to a life of crime you
can understand how it would have been
riley toby up now the ending of the
movie itself is very much about peter
almost killing the green goblin and
making the same mistakes that these
spider-man did however toby is there to
stop him and therefore he doesn't travel
down this dark path with his enemies
which will lead to a constant cycle of
violence thus the only way to really
save them was secure and reform them and
they actually love that the ending of
the movie is about healing the villains
instead of taking them down now because
of this most wouldn't have died upon
returning home norman osborne wouldn't
have impaled himself with his own glider
electro wouldn't have overcharged and
sandman wouldn't have turned to a life
of crime i'm not sure exactly what would
have happened with doc though as he
would have still had to have drowned
that miniature son but he may have
returned to an earlier moment i do think
that he might have just returned to the
moment he was afraid to die regain
control and then have drowned the son
anyway as he was definitely someone who
took responsibility for his actions how
this would affect those realities has
already been explained in end game and
an alternate timeline would simply
branch off whilst the rhyming garfield
films will continue in another reality
now another big thing that's happening
in the mcu is that they're finally
finally acknowledging the netflix shows
kingpin showed up at the end of hawkeye
episode 5 and matt murdock also appears
as peter's lawyer early on in the film
though we don't know what's happening in
the finale of hawkeye just yet we do
know that ekko is getting a solo show
down the line and it's likely that this
will be based on her origin story in the
comics we learned that kingpin killed
her father and in his dying breath he
asked the crime boss to take care of his
daughter she became one of his best
assassins whereas the show pinned her
dad's death on clint in the comics it
was daredevil who took the blame however
she discovered the truth eventually and
turn on her surrogate father which i do
believe will be the main plot of her
solo series they surely have to bring
daredevil into that too and there are
also rumors that he's gonna be in the
she-hulk series as well now though the
spell is supposed to have brought people
across at nupeta was spider-man venom
definitely didn't as he never met him
however the multiverse is a strange
thing and potentially when it broke open
because a venom in one universe knows
who he is every venom in every universe
had somewhat of a way to travel across
the tom hardy version possibly only got
taken over because he was currently
doing something that would massively
alter eddie's consciousness now lastly i
want to talk about doctor strange and
what happens next with him he doesn't
actually know why the multiverse is
broken open as he too would have been
hypnotized in forgetting it was
connected to be there therefore i think
that in the post-credits scene when we
catch him reaching out to wonder he's
going as a friend because he's confused
as to why this is happening this could
lead into the pair learning about peter
and in doing so they'll find out about
other versions of the character in other
realities this could lead to her
realizing that there are other versions
of her children and it could end up
leading us all into the multiverse of
madness say obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts and if you have other
questions i'm sure someone much smarter
than me can answer them so make sure you
leave them below we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the spider-man 4k
trilogies on the 30th of december all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the video we pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breaking of the full
movie which will be linked on screen
right now we talk about the plot the
ending and what could be happening in
the future so definitely head over there
right after this if not then thanks for
singing through the video i've been paul
you've been the best i'll see you in the
next one take care peace